[Music]
for 13 years paul velez was the
friendliest face at unlv as a member of
campus police he was a detective
information officer and served as
protection for the unlv football and
basketball teams he brought that sense
of duty from his 20-year tenure with the
nypd he also carries around a memory
that connects us all
this summer paul velez retired after 33
years of being a policeman he earned the
opportunity to bask in southern nevada
sunshine especially after his work on
the darkest day in american history
lower manhattan was just a giant
dust cloud
so as we were coming
into the ferry terminal
we couldn't see anything
on the morning of september 11th the
world stared terrified at its tv officer
paul velez put on his uniform and
blindly walked into catastrophe the pile
as it became known um
you know just trying to find people it
was just long lines of cops and firemen
filling up buckets and just passing them
down to get rubble out what we
romanticize as heroism
paul and his colleagues saw with watery
eyes as hysteria and kept going one of
the most haunting sounds as we were on
that pile for hours was people were
calling and still trying to get in touch
with their loved ones
and their cell phones were still
operating
so you heard cell phones going off and
constant beeping of the firefighters
rescue beacons were going off that were
trapped and deceased under there in a
city of 18 million people the terrorist
attacks hit hardest at home one velez
son as a cop and the other as a
firefighter so i'm we head down to the
ferry terminal to get deployed to
manhattan and
we're online waiting to get in and i
look over to my right
and there's my brother
getting on another boat and i still get
choked up thinking about it um
and
i couldn't believe it you know like and
we ran over to each other and you know
we were hugging hey you know be careful
you know don't become a hero you know
get home alive after working 30 straight
hours a new york tough guy has never
been so happy to see his brother you
know you come through the door and
there's my mom and she's hugging me and
crying and
i'm like i don't know where sal is she
points in the living room
[Music]
and he's sleeping on the couch
the attack on 9 11 wasn't just one day
or one week or one tragedy in the months
to come it was just
funeral after funeral after funeral this
policeman lives every day with what he
hopes no one else has to see you don't
want it to become just another
you know
show on the history channel paul velez
has retired with his beautiful wife in
las vegas but in the fall of 2001 he
worked 12-hour shifts for six straight
weeks in the haze of hell
he reminds us of a broken city and
united nation
may we never forget
amazing story
absolutely
we'll see at 11.